the school of life loves California
that's why we're so pleased to announce
that we were at last coming to LA with a
big three-day conference that we're
going to be running from the 22nd to the
24th of February 2019 taking place in
the Wilshire Ebell theatre just off
Wilshire Boulevard this is a three-day
event about everything we care about at
the School of Life emotional
intelligence wisdom self understanding
love friendship and meaning the
conference will mirror what happened in
our conferences in Lisbon Portugal in
October 2017 San Francisco in March 2018
and Zurich just this October that means
we'll have lectures in the day great
meals together the best kinds of
interactions and chats about everything
that matters late into the night it'll
be a true chance to experience a
globally minded community dedicated to
learning kindness self exploration and
wisdom the conference lasts three days
and is led by our founder and creative
lead Alain de Botton and will feature
our best teachers and our very best and
most transformative ideas if you're
interested in coming to LA to meet us in
February please click on the link on
screen now you'll learn a lot returned
with a huge number of useful new ideas
and make friends for life we hope to see
you there